hi Brian Regan hey what time is your
show Saturday I I don't know okay you're
at Carnegie Hall on Saturday night yes
and you also a Netflix Pesci what is
your Netflix special in November 21st
November 21st what you call it nunchucks
and flamethrowers why that I just picked
two words at random out of the day there
no it's a punch line from one of the
jokes in the middle of my show so uh do
you the hard time picking a name for I
don't know what to call something yes
yes it's a that's the hardest part of
the whole thing you do an hour you work
on it for a couple of years and then
they go what are you gonna title it and
it's a I don't know man
it's like when you go to a museum and
you see this beautiful painting and it's
just called woman walking woman she's
walking you know it's also like if
you're naming after your punch lines
like you're your previous specials like
people have their favorite jokes set out
from those specials right so it's like
you have to figure out before anybody
sees it which one is gonna be that joke
that people are gonna be like cuz
otherwise they're like why don't you
name it after that job yeah I don't like
I don't like I also don't like coming up
with track titles do you have to do that
when you come out with a yeah I never
I've never enjoyed it
no sometimes you go with the most
sometimes we it's the first couple you
try to be funny and and and clever and
get something that people go huh that's
a great name and then and then you know
for specials and it's woman walking just
to get it done yeah I remember the the
first CD I had to come up with track
titles and I was on a flight and it was
like a deadline so I wrote I wrote down
all these track titles and this is
before cellphones and I got to some
airport and I had to get in a payphone
and and called the person who was gonna
put the track titles down and I'm at a
payphone with other people listening to
me saying monster trucks doughnut lady
these people are
put me on with the monster-truck donut
hole do you name your tour now you're on
a tour it's probably a lot of different
material did you name this tour no no I
when I first went out when I first
started playing like the the larger
places I was told to put a title on the
tour so I did that for the first year
and then the second year but I I don't
like it because people think that that
hour of material is that title you know
so I just I just go Brian Regan I'm
performing you know in concert that's a
better idea I named - they told me to
but I probably won't again until the
special comes out there's no reason to
your right is the thinking that if you
don't name it people aren't gonna
realize it's a different show than the
last time you were in town I think they
just like it for marketing reasons you
know there's some clever cutesy title on
there and they could say the you know
such-and-such tour but I I cringe at it
you know I'd rather it's just if they
don't want to come see me without some
title then I don't want them coming oh
yeah I probably shy had followed that -
suggestion I had a hard time this time
like I just didn't wanna the idea of
naming the tour before the special yeah
yeah way before changes like I I've
watched some of your older stuff
recently and it's like you're definitely
a different guy now than you were 20
years ago I try to I try to evolve you
know I try to talk about things that
interest me you know I'm talking about
kim jeong-hoon and guns and things that
would surprise people but I also like to
talk about just mundane stuff as well so
a little of everything so hard for
people to accept it for me like if you
talk about other stuff or they're cool
it um I think they might
be a little I don't know I don't know
but I can't worry about it you know I
mean yeah you think it's dance or you
just say is it just jokes III try to be
crafty you know like the the the gun
stuff you know I I I say that I'm in the
middle on guns you know and then I have
this thing about how I go to big
meetings for people in the middle on
guns and like I'm the only guy in the
bar whom you know because people are
either one way or another and then I I
have this thing about when people try to
explain and this is true I I don't
understand the difference between an
assault weapon and a non assault weapon
and anytime somebody explains the
difference on TV I'm always more
confused at the end of the explanation
it's always some guy going yeah you got
people out there trying to tell you that
at 2:27 for for a double-action boat a
16 clip with a 40 mag and somehow
supposed to be the same as for 27 single
pole double action 32 clip with a 34
pole that's like that's like saying a
for 22 to 27 hunting rifle with a
detachable scope and a 17 clip is
supposed to be the same as for 27 single
action double bolt 14 mag and I'm like
my melting brain before the segment yeah
you know and it's true I I don't I stay
whenever that it's explained I don't
know what the heck they're talking about
do you like that are you happy you
you're in Vega I think of you a lot when
I feel like how much how easy your
flights must be being in Vegas you can
fly anywhere at any time there's always
a [ __ ] plane leaving Las Vegas and
I'm always flying against the grain I'm
flying out when people are coming in so
I don't have to wait in lines I'm going
everyone's going to Vegas for the
weekend that's when I'm leaving Vegas
alright so I don't have to get in those
huge security lines how do you avoid the
u.s. the gambling and all that stuff and
all the vices I don't I I drink I I
womanized there's nothing I'd love more
than you being busted like the [ __ ]
senator and Godfather two
yeah that would be fun
no I I mean I don't I don't i gamble
like I'd like to play blackjack every
now and then you do it um yeah but not a
lot well half you holla you sit at the
table for if you go to do it until I'm
down enough where it's time for me to
head home
really yeah I I occasionally go into
those high limit rooms you know where
you can act like a big shot by the way
this is skirting a very far away from
the original statement of Oh every now
and then I sit down at the blackjack
exactly I like the high limit rooms but
but once a month you know I'll go in
there what are the high limit rooms
what's the limit on a Highlander $100
$100 a hint and we're hungry dollars a
hand is the limit on a high limit room
you can't bet less than that Oh
some is the bottle it's the bottom
that's the bottle okay and how many
hands at a time you play just one okay
one at a time and you know but if I'm
down like a thousand then I just go home
i I don't I'm not gonna hurt myself a
thousand now because Brian's a humble
guy that means if he's down ten thousand
he's not gonna come if he's down ten
Jesus everybody has like one one moment
where they're just like you know what
screw it let's get correct who is there
is there an amount the most that you
spent on one hand that isn't typical the
most I've ever bet on a hand is $500 is
that right yeah but that I will only do
that if I'm up like if I'm up like $700
isn't then I'll risk it and put 500 and
then I'll lose yeah I'm
I really don't gamble that much you know
it's like every once in a while will you
raised Miami Florida you are okay yeah
nicely my my dad recently passed away he
passed away about five months ago
oh [ __ ] Simon that's all right he was 90
lived a good long life and my mom is
still around she's 90 was it was it
expected or was it suddenly died I think
when you're 90
it's you kind of always away for
yeah yes all right yeah you just kind of
wait for the phone call you know time
the phone rings you're like I gotta call
the travel agent hello you know you got
a trap that's right anytime my oldest
brother would call like over the last
five years I always thought that was
like the call you know but uh that is
the age where people stop asking cause
of death right yeah he was 90 and
they're like nobody goes like whoa oh
how did it go he's 90 you know what's
weird I don't even know what is the
technical thing right yeah that's kind
of stop
well sometimes someone's in the hospital
for six months and they're like all
right and then other times I got another
heart attack and they just you know we
knew it but we weren't expecting it
today right right right
but yeah so anyway I figure once you get
to 90 you've won the race you know so he
had a good long life and and my mom's
still kicking around she is right yeah
what did he do my dad was an accountant
for Eastern Airlines yes [ __ ] Eastern
Air what history I do I wish I didn't
[Laughter]
Eastern Airlines go belly-up I don't
know exactly but they went bankrupt they
went bankrupt what there was some
there was a strike you know the
machinists are on strike or something
like that and then they finally just
went bankrupt it was a weird thing
because like the these people were on
strike and they wanted the the higher
ups one of them to settle and then the
the airline said we don't have any money
we're going bankrupt and then all the
people who are on strike started
cheering and celebrating and I found
that weird why are they celebrating I
don't know it's like like all right we
took the airline down but okay but
everybody's out of a job celebrate for
an hour and then and then where are you
going right now you're not going to work
yeah yeah throw a party and then the
bill comes and they're all looking
around like well I don't have a job
anymore I'm not yes was he out of work
for a while or no yeah yeah he started a
business when he was done with Eastern
Airlines sealcoating
driveways in Miami Florida now why an
older guy would want to be out in the
hot Sun is beyond me but you know my
brother Dennis yeah brother Dennis he's
a stand-up but he worked with my dad for
a while and they were sealcoating a
parking lot in Miami Florida and they
said this car pulled up with four guys
in it this is Miami Florida now and the
guys honked the horn and Dennis looked
over and these guys said what's the next
state and here's their what what's the
next state and Dennis goes Georgia and
they said thanks and it took it was to
committed some crime and they thought if
they crossed the state line they'd be
free or something or yeah what are what
are the state law you're going there's
there is no other state going the other
way Panhandle to the left okay I may say
so going north there in Miami Florida so
which way you know what's the next state
Dennis goes Georgian is it which way so
he pointed north and they said thanks
and took off that's somebody's still in
the commission of a crime that's not the
crime is done that's it something is
still happening right there's a lot of
adrenaline coursing through the brain at
that yeah they didn't plan the getaway
and Brian's at Carnegie Hall it's this
Saturday 8 o'clock yeah if you want to
catch Brian this Saturday 8 o'clock and
if you can't make it out then the
Netflix special is November 21st
nunchucks and flamethrowers I saw you
two on on Loudermilk yeah I saw the
first few episodes of it and it struck
me as a very non Brian Regan character I
said you're great in it well that's very
nice to hear it's a Peter Farrelly
directed series Peter Farrelly and Bobby
Mort created it it's a 10 episode series
on DIRECTV's audience Network it's
called Loudermilk and it's about
substance abuse right and I play a guy
recovering from substance abuse and
woman I see so no you have you have you
uh because you don't you've done a lot
of stuff that's no I would have out of
your kind of ballpark out of character
for you the only other
acting I had done was that Chris Rock
top five movie I write tiny part in that
which was shot a try studios right
couple other people in this room have a
little yeah you can't meowing that too
in there right well you know so that was
the only other thing I had done and then
I did this Loudermilk thing it's ten
episodes and it was kind of cool man
were you avoiding acting or is it just
not happening no one no one wanted me to
do anything I was going to a lot of
auditions I wasn't avoiding it it's so I
wasn't getting anything you've been so
successful and standing up for so long I
like you didn't doing theaters first and
you would think that people would be
like it's good quality Carlin like
career though which was so much step but
I drew a tremendously successful stamp
career right we were doing huge theaters
you're making a great living you're
doing TV like as a stand-up that you you
really can't get any higher so the
acting stuff is like fine but you don't
need it right that that's kind of well I
mean I I appreciate that that's kind of
where it came to I I always thought you
I wanted to get on some acting thing to
get to the point where I could play
larger venues and then when I was able
to play the larger venues without doing
it it was like III didn't really need
anything else but I just liked it for
the fun of it now you Dre right you
enjoy it and it's one of those things
where I like it if the script is good or
if I like to because there's so much of
that you read like yeah just [ __ ]
terrible right
did you read for this so they offered to
you he just offered it to me he saw me
do stand-up
Jackie Flynn another comedian brought
Peter Farrelly to watch me perform I was
at this I Love Lucy Comedy Festival in
the caliber that I guess I guess Lucille
Ball is from near Jamestown New York so
they have a comedy festival it's
actually a pretty cool festival anyway
so I peter farrelly saw me perform there
and said he was doing this series and
asked if I wanted to be in it and I was
like usually when people tell you things
like that
they just walk they walk that way and
you walk this way and that you never
hear from them again but he followed
through don't you find there's less
pressure with that too like if somebody
already likes you and they go no no I
want you to do it like you okay cool
they just their hint that they know I
can do it I don't have to they want me
to be me yeah less pressure associated
with exactly exactly
it is funny though because like you go
to Montreal and like the young comics
like yeah man it used to be like you do
this and somebody would find you and
they discover you and it's just not
happening anymore in blah blah blah but
then it's because everybody's getting
discovered at the I Love Lucy communist
everybody's going to the wrong City man
nothing's happening in Montreal it's all
I Love Lucy now in Jamestown is is is
though is the weirdest place to cuz
you're the festival and there's that bar
and then comics like I'm gonna take a
little walk around the bar and it's like
nothing's gonna happen there right fine
if you want to see some friends or just
do gigs but you not get not [ __ ] next
ninety five thing you stop it just
hanging know she doesn't give a [ __ ]
about you you're talking to him for 10
minutes and he's gonna forget you were
alive 10 minutes later I was in Montreal
one time and this guy came up to me and
he's chatting with me and you know I
didn't know who he was and but I'm just
being sociable friendly and we're
talking for five minutes and then the
guy goes what um what what do you book
again well and I said oh I don't I don't
book anything he goes well I thought you
were a Booker I said no I'm a comedian
I'm a stand-up comedian and he goes ah
and he just turned around don't you wish
you knew who that was it just turned
like I've meant nothing to him
from that point on like this guy can do
nothing for me he didn't even say
goodbye he'd turn around and walked away
he's not gonna waste three seconds yeah
saying goodbye yeah and he felt like an
[ __ ] because he was doing his [ __ ]
best pitch to another comic humiliating
yeah I'll try to make a call for you
buddy but he's your path your cross
paths with them again I don't remember I
don't even know what the guy looked like
can you imagine turning the charm on and
like doing the the dance that we do for
people that can help [ __ ]
all right yeah I I did an industry
showcase a long time ago and my manager
who's great Rory rose garden fantastic
guy but we were new with each other and
he didn't really know my personality yet
he said all right I want you to go stand
by the door as everyone's leaving like
all the industry people and I said I'm
not doing that I'm not doing that I
don't I don't want anything that bad I
don't want anything that bad where I'm
standing by a door as people are walking
out that just seems very your hands in
your pockets I'd rather not get a TV
show then get one here's Jimmy and Brian
he's saying that and as he's saying that
they today in 2017 I'm making a mental
note stand by the door that's a great
idea
my manager never suggested that I think
I don't even like industry I don't even
like doing industry comps like I always
say that like I don't want to do Compson
industry because half the time they
don't come there's an empty table and
there's shitty in the audience because
they just I just don't want them to come
I don't enjoy when they're there it's
not comfortable they're not typically
fun especially when you're on stage yeah
I see an empty table and you're like
that's the industry table and like you
know as you're performing nope
they didn't show I did the Viper Room by
2008 whoa rock and roll was the first
comedian to do it but I mean you guys
talked about 200 seats a clip empty
table because it's so small and I knew
exactly the industry that never came I
knew the Asia I still remember his name
and I will still go nowhere near that
agency because I [ __ ] hate this guy
so much for making a big deal about
getting ticket so the agents that asked
for tickets and then don't even have the
courtesy to say look I can't make it
it's an unforgivable shitty thing to do
yeah yeah yeah not fun so the you were
the first comedian to perform at the
Viper Room
I believe so at least molest my agent
lights maybe she might have highly
possible yeah make you feel good the
first one to do a weekend there got
popular pick about 1978 go [ __ ] liar
it'll pop up on the internet you know
first comedian ever to perform not Jim
Norton yeah
thirty seventh one in the worst-selling
was a bad weekend who the real comedian
cancelled so humiliating story that I
never knew existed the industry was
there that table was empty because you
couldn't sell the tickets yeah maybe
that's what it was maybe they maybe my
agent just blame somebody else and said
that they didn't come you ever fill in
for somebody I I had to fill in for
somebody one time at a show I'm on stage
I was bombing so I get off stage and I'm
like like what the hell just happened
and somebody came up to me and said how
come you didn't make us act like
chickens and stuff and I said what and
they showed me the table tent the guy
replaced was a comedy hypnotist they
didn't tell the audience so they thought
that I was a hypnotist they're probably
just wondering when is he gonna stop
doing these stupid jokes and get up
bring us on stage I'm here to be and do
some goofy stuff that's humiliating and
that's annoying if they just didn't tell
you you could have addressed that in the
first - I know I know I could have said
on your table ten since this comedy
hypnotist I'm not that those people
bought tickets specifically for a
hypnotism show they find a hypnotist to
replace the guy that's just one comedy
hypnotist yeah well people make big
mistakes have you uh have you snapped at
an audience at all in recent years
because you're such an affable guy on
stage and so funny but there's got to be
at least the occasional drunken dick
even at your show sure yeah I mean it
well not so much in the you know
theatres because people you know they're
they're paying for a ticket than other
people don't but the comedy club level
yeah I I would I didn't do it a lot but
I snapped occasionally the pre pre
YouTube yeah I'm a Youtube snap you know
you're conscious of that though like you
know you're like nope YouTube exists I
won't be even though it happens you're
like I'm not going to be doing anything
that I don't want on the Internet yeah I
mean because that stuff can take your
career down you know I mean but yeah
I've gotten angry before yeah it happens
once in a while and it said the I guess
especially if you're doing something out
of character by being angry and yelling
at people right but I can't see are you
Brian if you have
he's a townhome I mean he on a town hall
in front Saturday but it's after Brian
so you can go see him first he said you
really tend to flood that so he could
plug in I actually because Kearney is a
bigger gig and I'm surprised if you're
not sold out you're probably very close
to it so if you want to see Brian eight
o'clock he's brilliant and it thank you
it's literally the most universal
economic I've ever seen I've never
comedians [ __ ] [ __ ] on everyone
you're one of the only guys you want to
tell and maybe Colin are the only guys
I've never heard comics [ __ ] on like
your audience the [ __ ] bikers black
people white people old it's the most
universal yeah audience any comedian has
I think and I appreciate it and it's
really really funny man and Brian's a
guy that other comedians watch and it
doesn't matter who you are you'll enjoy
it so if you want to see him on Saturday
night and then if you really want to
drop off after like if you need up if
you need if you need sorbet after a
brilliant show come to town hall and
I'll go that's right it's not all Brian
Regan when did you first realize that
like you had jokes that were resonating
to the point that you had to do because
I saw you I mean it was years ago is in
Syracuse and you're performing at a
theater but you did the thing at the end
where you allowed people to request bits
which was I think partly so that they
didn't shout them out during the regular
the regular right but like that you had
people that were so attached to specific
bits that you had to do that because not
all comics know it's in this room have
to do that it's very it's very
flattering that's for sure
but I I don't like it during the main
part of my show because it's like I you
probably like you we want to do the most
recent stuff you know like monster rain
and chip tripperz and being shouted
people yell out monster in a lot and
chip-chip person they'll yell but I
always say I'll do them at the end if
people don't yell and that people are
cool with that too because it's a stupid
category but if I do chip early it's
just unfollow Bowl and they hate my guts
and can't follow chip no I want them to
yell that at my show I just created a
nightmare because I know somebody now is
going to yell that Brian is daring you
to y'all chips down so funny if anybody
Sacco or your pink garbage people are
literally now buying tickets to Carnegie
Hall so that they can just yell chanting
and how long is your show to you about
an hour and 15 hour half yeah I do I
don't know why I like sixty five minutes
I don't know why I wrap my head around
that I like to do 65 credits an hour and
then I do an encore after that what are
you doing the Encore I never do encores
I'm so happy to get dude it's amazing I
walk off and I'm like I'm so happy that
they enjoy I'm so afraid they're not
gonna enjoy it
what are you doing Rock hold you do
material or old stuff or just talk to
them it depends i I mean I go out and if
they shout stuff out then I'll try to
you know do a couple of older bits but
if they don't shout out then I just have
a couple of things I can go to you know
what was your encore five ten minutes
okay just I don't do a long thing and do
it again and it sounds or it's such a
stupid and fruity question are you
comfortable at this point I still have
this moment I walk out I'm like I'm
completely confident and comfortable
then there's other days where I'm like
I'm [ __ ] a fraud and I'm nervous and
I'm not I feel frightened like you still
have that at all or are you completely
beyond that um no I just I I just had
some pretty humbling experiences
Saturday I was doing some guest spots at
the Laugh Factory in Las Vegas good
comedy club and I was supposed to be on
Fallon this week but Fallon's mother
passed away all the shows this week are
canceled so I was just running my set in
front of you know audiences that didn't
know anything about me and ate it they
always really yeah yeah it's very um
it's weird
wait were you just going on as a guest
spot yeah yeah I was just doing the five
minutes the five minutes that was
supposed to be headline it was like
Cedric the Entertainer it was like not
your audience or was it Michael Davis a
comedian juggler okay
he was the headliner and you know he's
gracious enough to let me do five
and by late you know shitty this as a
headline I was like Brian Regan wants to
go on oh no do you feel what he eats it
when it's the one for free
to watch him bomb every night it was so
I don't wanna say like it's bizarre like
I'm but it was weird for me you know to
because usually I'm going on in front of
people who are there to see me they know
you they know me and it's hard not to do
at least okay but what if I'm going out
to a roomful of strangers who knew
nothing about me I can be just as
hit-or-miss as anybody else does it make
you like when you this was nice for your
like alright I'm sucking but I know I
can't get out of it and then you have
those moments whether it's running it's
not like that were you're like I can't
get out of this like all the tricks I
know there's no way to pull out of this
I'm legitimately bombing and I'm just
bombing right and I can't pull out and
it's scary and it's also like amazing oh
yeah that's why people are afraid of
this that's because you forgetting after
a while why people are scared to do
stand-up you like yeah that's great it's
comfortable and it's fun and you're like
oh thanks what is it yeah I felt like I
was hit by a train I mean I was
literally like on stage you know doing
the you know just not resonating with
the people like I had to go do that like
in years you know like just bombing
jokes you know and those the opening
joke do you know you walk out you say
hello they like it did you have a
special guest Brian Regan you say hello
to remember what your opening line was
your opening how were your opening well
I I do a thing about my having my my dad
recently passed away you know what I
mean and then I do these jokes about his
sense of humor so what I did is I went
out and I said so my dad my dad recently
passed away and then the opening joke is
hey that's a great way to start a comedy
show and hopefully they laugh at you and
that I'm go from there well they didn't
laugh oh I said my dad recently passed
away and I said that's a great way to
start a comedy show and they were
looking at me like no it's not and then
I said he had a great sense of humor and
they were looking at me like we can't
get past the fact that you just told you
exactly now you are
they all laugh at that opening do you
know like this is gonna go really poorly
if I don't have them there I'm not gonna
be able to get them here definitely a
red alert light alert light went on in
my head like well usually I'm riding it
from that point yeah and then I started
going into the bits and they just stared
at me oh did it feel like a long five
minutes yeah yeah you have to go back
and see the other comic and and the
other comedians all know you you're
Brian Reed but then you have to walk off
it what are you saying the other boy
that was are you it's very humbling you
know because uh I mean the other
comedians know who I am the audience I
don't think had a clue who I was and not
that I care egle wise but sure yeah in a
way though isn't like like it's
cleansing in a way like yep this can
still happen like you never totally
beyond that correct i I think if comedy
was foolproof it would be boring it
would be boring if it was a hundred
percent guaranteed it's like I don't
think a bowler would a bowler want to
know he could bowl a strike every time I
think it's better to earn earn it you
know what I mean it feels better I don't
know why I'm using a pretty much what we
do I mean we knock down the pins with
laughter so on some level are you like I
got to do more of these little guest
spot things so that this happens more so
I get reminded of it because it's very
crushing and humbling the idea of it
being actually there is some good to it
you're like but I that doesn't mean I
want to do it ever again I wanted to
close my set with what's the next state
and then run to the next state Hey
when someone asks you I got asked this
in interview so this is G what makes you
laugh
like I'll miss sometimes mention
comedians but a lot of times I say this
honestly I'll say a comedian bombing
makes me laugh and it's not to be hipper
because I but it literally just me I
guess because you relate to it so much
and you get it and it's so different and
so funny but to watch a guy up there
especially guy you know is good just
eating his dick and you watch them
trying to use the tricks that work and
none of those tricks are working right
it really makes me laugh to watch it's
it makes you feel good not because you
want to see somebody die but it's
comforting to know it can happen to any
of us you know I mean it is it is
comforting to know and I've seen like
all every good comedian I've seen
Chappelle eat his dick and Chris Rock
will go on Damon Wayans for legendary
he'd walk on a bomb for an hour just
talking and working through stuff and
you're like that's why he's a great
comic because he doesn't care like he
cares about the material but he's not
afraid of getting stared out when he's
working and that that's you know I saw
Garry Shandling perform at a charity
thing and he went out and wasn't doing
well for like five minutes but was so
calm and ended up turning it around
we're like they were just eating out of
the palm of his hand by the end of us
said and I'm thinking I I don't have
that kind of comfort you don't I mean I
would be scrambling in my head and
trying to fix things so once there he
was going down you're going down with it
like there's no bringing it back up I'm
not I'm not good at that yeah I'm not
good at you know whatever it starts out
at it kind of keeps going in that dress
well he's probably faking if you ask
Gary about that he probably would have
said the entire time I was thinking of
pumping a bullet in my head like the
whole time he was probably like oh I
suck I'm [ __ ] Pat you're probably
panicking it's the whole thing is just a
lie of acting like this is exactly how
it's meant to be always right and of
course I'm not getting laughs I'm not
expecting them at this moment we're on a
show mode what's that like you're just
completely putting on a show it doesn't
relate at all to what's going on in your
head you're just like Jess just put
something out there make them believe
something else well yeah I mean what
that's correct you you you go into
performance mode to take okay I do have
certain tricks and things that I can do
to make this look like this is what's
supposed to be happening but IIIi
wonder what that laugh factory audience
thought like I wonder if they thought
does he just talk for five minutes no
one laughs we had a better time watching
Michael Richards at the Laugh Factory at
the County saw and I'm and I'm just I'm
doing terribly where the new stuff is
just not working and then I'll start to
get a couple of laughs and I'll state
like you said you stay calm and I'm like
you know what in your head you're like
okay the material is not is doing
nothing tonight so what I'm working on
is just the staying calm and [ __ ]
working through a bomb run me and
turning it around so you're feeling I'm
getting something out of it like I'm
it's not a total loss but I've actually
said it to myself on stage all right
dude do it make this a personality thing
where you just [ __ ] walking through
it and see if you can get them from a
total bomb because otherwise I'm just
gonna get frustrated and saben Rises get
something out of it that's something out
of it I mean I'm happy to hear it
happens to you I mean Jesus Christ
happens to Regan it can happen to any of
them it made your day a little bit oh my
god yeah I'm not there's nothing I would
love to see more that's a really rare
thing that never happen in the theaters
no of course not you usually know right
no because there you know they have a
ticket with your name on it right they
know who you are you know I mean do you
work out by going out like would you
actually write [ __ ] down or you just go
on and try an idea that you have I have
like bullet points of new things I want
to hit and you know I and --which them
in between stronger stuff and give it a
shot you know but that's one thing
that's good about comedy is when it is
going well and one bit that doesn't work
is fine because you can just joke about
it not working yeah you can acknowledge
it that's why acting is hard cuz you
can't acknowledge right well boy I'm not
believable like airline pilot can't joke
about messing up going man I did not see
that mountain yeah but we can we can
mess up at our job and joke about it and
people go yeah okay that's funny I guess
and you can you can kind of talk about
it which do you ever do stuff like we
like could you make a good living do you
do stuff or you're like oh god if my
fans could see me bitching about this
like and there are times where they'll
call me out and I'm like they're right
you know I mean like you know I bitched
about sometimes I'm justified to [ __ ]
about the airlines because they were
service industry and they sucked but
thank guys who go shut up you fly
everywhere in the country and you're you
know and your life is good shut the [ __ ]
up and then you're like yeah he has a
point to like their luxury problems some
of the things like I'm complaining that
the hotel suite I mean doesn't that
feather pillows like I really am it I I
tweeted one time I was on a plane and I
was frustrated because we had landed and
it took him 20 minutes to get to the the
gate so I tweeted about you know it's
great to land on time and not be able to
you know I was frustrated and then
somebody tweeted back louis ck's bit you
know what making fun of people like me
complaining and it actually was it put
me on the right track you know because
it was like you know what they're right
I I just flew somewhere I'm I'm I'm
sitting on a plane for 20 minutes it
life life is fine they are correct and
Louie's bit was brilliant I think he did
on Conan about the chair in the sky
however when I was in LAX and they
didn't have a gate ready and we had to
pull out off to the side of the tarmac
and sit for two hours they could have
sent me all the Louis bits in the world
and I would have been a [ __ ] I
would've said [ __ ] him in his bit two
hours of sitting on the tarmac is
inexcusable their services there is all
the point where the Louis bit is like no
I'm right to be mad
and if we have the technology to put
chairs in the sky we should have the
technology to be able to get out of the
chairs once the planes you're not in the
sky anymore I don't know why every one
of those concourses doesn't have a gate
that's just for unloading the fact that
you have to wait for a gate to open up
right before you can go in is ridiculous
you know if somebody lands on time there
should be some gate where at least
everybody can just get off right I mean
yeah it doesn't have to be assigned to
it's just maybe like a spare gate a
spare gate that if a plane is there and
on time and people need to make
connections you don't have to wait for
this other plane to come out because an
exit an exit yeah I forget how they do
that though it's also expensive and they
have to fight hard for that space and
that not like that's why certain
airports like the one airline will have
all the great spots and then like you if
you know the other airline is like in
terminal D and you got to take a train
to get to it yeah I'm boring myself at
this point if it's any consolation
a real serious [ __ ] statement about
airline policy right you hate that
terminal pi really all kidding aside
oh [ __ ] yourself Jim who cares you make
a good point
how many kids you have two you do 18
year old and a 14 year old a daughters
our sons a boy and a girl who's older
my son is older okay how how you as a
dad I wasn't ask you about before are
you like with especially the daughter
and boys coming around now you like a
strict set the guy down type of father i
I have I beat them like at the beginning
of each week for what they're going to
do I'll say all right because because I
have like scheduling issues because I
travel yeah so um I beat them on and
beat them on Mondays yeah because I know
they're gonna do something wrong and
there's a lot of people out there going
that's he shouldn't be doing beating
jokes no they think it's a great idea
what you're saying it's admiring your
it's not it's not you're ahead of the
game it's not like yeah I have to beat
them on Monday for what they did over
the weekend no no no you have to stay
ahead of this stuff no I'd like to think
I'm a decent dad you know I try to be so
uh who knows are you strict I'm saying
are you more of a strict like or you
kind of like I'll let them breathe a
little or do you know I'm not super
strict um I remember putting my son and
time out when he was a kid because I'm
certainly never gonna lay a hand on my
children but putting him in timeout
and he looked over it was like two and
just looked gave me a look that was like
it just crushed me and I went get out of
timeout I couldn't do it you're never
doing timeout again so you don't hit
your kids either like that the message
has gotten out like you know what I mean
you know our Father did you apparently
don't hit your kids but I'm saying like
our generation our parents hit us my
[ __ ] I got soap in the mouth I got hit
did you get hurt not my dad would slap
our hand he would say put your hand out
and then he would take his watch off you
did not want you didn't want we didn't
want dad to take his watch off my dad
had a bad hand he was in an accident
when he was young
so he only had one good hand and he had
to take the watch off that good hand to
slap us and we had to put our hand out
and he would just slap it hard but if
you gave like if you pulled your hand
down that would that would really get
him riled and so you had to just stand
there and take this the slaps would it
be for justifiable reasons yeah yeah but
when you look back on and it wasn't like
horrible he was just slapping you on the
palm of your hand you yeah yeah and it's
weird how that was so normal and then
you parents like now I don't know I
don't hit at all I guess it is kind of
fun it is [ __ ] up if you're out and
you see somebody slap their kids so
watching kids get hit and watch
comedians bomb it's like until it's my
turn to be funny in this let's discuss
the airline financial reasons why the
gate situation I I went to Catholic
school and the nuns would hit us and one
day I had a horrible sunburn and I asked
my mom to write a note asking our my
teacher the nun to not hit me that day
because and I don't know what I don't
know why the note wasn't please don't
ever hit my son please don't hit my son
today right because he's gonna bat
sunburn until it starts to peel what
starts to peel all bets are off your
right to note yeah my mom wrote the note
please don't hit please don't hit my son
today because he's got a bad sunburn I
wish I kept that yeah that's a great
note yeah no no I was at the board and I
couldn't solve a problem which of course
requires a beating corporal punishment
you know so so she was she was slapping
me on the back you know you should know
this answer and then she remembered that
she wasn't supposed to hit me oh no tell
me not to tell my mom she said don't
tell don't tell your mother that I hit
you okay why we're so [ __ ] up as a
dolt like that does not really crazy way
to grow up
now she's beating you and
not to tell your parents about it yeah
like she and I are together on right you
know like we're gonna keep this from
your mom
that's probably why millenials are you
know the way stereotypically Millennials
ours because your generation all got
beaten yeah and so then you go the other
way and you guys are all parents now
raising kids that you'd you're like I
would never do that to my kids so many
parents now like just just like dote on
the kids not you guys specifically but
so many parents will dote on the kids
and no real like no no no I don't want I
just want to make you happy I just want
to make you happy I just want to make
you happy and now you've got a
generation of adults or young adults
that have these entitlement issues
because they've always gotten what they
wanted because their parents got beaten
up does that make sense it's absolute
end alum went too far right yes exactly
right along too far in the other
direction now we can only hope to bring
things back to the greatest generation
that these Millennials have kids and
just kick them like light nipple torture
I feel bad for kids that are being born
today because the pendulum is starting
to come back oh yeah weird quirks like
are you a like a an OCD guy or do you
have any odd little little personality
things I I have OCD I suffer from OCD
you do we should I always think is a bit
of a strong word
yeah is it suffering people know it's
the people around you who suffer right
people in today's world say they suffer
from things when twenty years ago they
just dealt with them you know but I have
a little bit of the the OCD thing what
has it come out for you organizing
things you know I I think it helps with
my comedy but it sure hinders me in in
everyday life what do you like when you
when you see this in front of me right
now is it driving you nuts I like the
yellow highlight park hi Jeff how are
you Jeff Ross is coming to join us I
hope you don't mind
good see buddy how you doing we're just
talking about a Brian's talk about OCD a
little bit and what is it you organize
everything everything like is your house
neat is everything like
color-coordinated or how do you do your
stuff when I because I grew up in a big
family
when it was completely chaotic it was
when I went to college that I realized I
could start organizing things without
you know somebody else messing it up and
I would like organize my closet like the
jackets were on the right and then the
long-sleeve shirts and then the
shortened sleeve shirts and then the
t-shirts give it try not doing it yeah
but it's not comfortable it just feels
like something's wrong right it's like I
got to get it all organized I've seen
you preparing for your act years and
years and years ago and everything is
really organized Todd Barry and I just
found our way in your in your hotel room
in Princeton once and everything there's
like whiteout and pencil and all this
paper I was like oh okay well this is
how you get great do you do that you
call it like now like when you're
writing stuff out is there a way your
system you have I to me it's like
impossible to completely organize it but
it's a constant quest yeah yeah I like
to keep but but I do think it helps with
the comedy because it's like you know
you're organizing words or organizing
bits you're organizing everything so it
helps with that does it drive the wife
nuts no longer married oh you're not did
I know that about your kids like does
that mean like you insist on they being
no no guys no no no no I would never put
that on them how long you been divorced
or not six years okay six years
are you dating Aaron oh there any hot
Browns is it one of those things where
you get kind ever got married on we fto
qiamat for a while you but you're an
established guy you still look really
good you're not like you're [ __ ] you
know you flirting thank you no I'm
complimenting a friend okay you I'm so
good you're a great body
but do you do you now like try after a
show okay I now I can start doing this
which I haven't done in a long time
where you start and you start trying to
meet somebody or beyond a dating app so
no no I don't do the apps but you know I
it would be nice to hook up with
somebody and ride the rest of this life
out how about this if there's any women
out there and you want a handsome really
funny guy who is quite financially
established don't be a dope try to pick
them off after Carnegie Hall
yes Saturday night yeah but but like
because I'm OCD lined up alphabetically
[Laughter]
anyway how about you Jeff for you are
you a starting single or not yeah how
long it's been a couple years now you
liking it or no I mean it's the longest
I've ever been single so I guess it's
all still pretty new why are you I'm
meaning not like why did you break up
but why are you not trying or you just
I'm always trying I just haven't found
the right person
okay I'm going out like on dates sure
all the time what happens they're fun
usually fun try hard I'm a good a good
boyfriend when I find somebody somebody
sent me a picture of you recently this
is - I forgot about this it was fun
dating app and go my friend wants to
know if this is Jeff and I wrote back I
go yes it's him so I'm also I'll show it
to you and we make sure it's actually
you okay that'd be good yeah I hope it's
gonna be a fake account later on JDate
it was not no it was not J dates the
it's like Jewish Andrew where you swipe
in the opposite direction I have not no
heard of it I have yeah I joined black a
black people dating site once I want to
date I haven't dated a black girl in so
many years I just like I would love to
it I just didn't pan out I'd say shocker
I can't believe it
yeah you didn't have success on the
black dating website no but why not I
know people crossed race I have I just
haven't in a long time I just wanted to
did you put that in your profile hey
guys I might not be black but I know
people cross races it's not that unusual
a thing to date out of your
is not unusual so that's one two but I
don't think that people going to a black
dating website are probably looking to
date interracially you probably correct
because that was my Korean choices all
right 500 pictures on there and you're
the only white guy yep why would a woman
go to a black dating website to find Jim
mm-hmm that's a correct uh yes so you
got there already and they did not okay
oh there it is JDate